joe burrow acknowledges the obvious and
we've discussed this previously the idea
that
if you uh don't have college football
season this year it is going to
significantly impact your draft stock he
says i feel for college athletes right
now i hope their voices are heard by the
decision makers if this happened a year
ago i may be looking for a job right now
he's right because chris he came out of
essentially nowhere his first season
with lsu was not impressive he told me
before the draft the difference between
first season and second season he went
back
decided to work on his footwork get his
feet under him when he was making off
platform throws and it made all the
difference in the world his statistics
went from
ah to incredible right from one year to
the next he
he may not have been drafted at all if
there hadn't been a 2019 college
football season
so uh that's part of the reality here
this final opportunity
for guys who will be drafted april of
2021
to to change the opinions that are
currently floating out there
as to what kind of a player they are and
it could go
from from a good opinion to a bad one
but it also could go from a bad opinion
or no opinion to a great one
those opportunities to get better or get
worse you're going to be completely lost
if there's no college football yeah
no i mean you know joe burrows the
ultimate success story the guy that
works hard you know there's
there's a lot of growing that goes in
you know
to that last year of college football i
think sometimes as
people who watch football from afar and
now you know i'm about to be 40 and
you're 55
you know we forget that they're young
kids still they're growing kids
that you know the difference between a
sophomore to a junior or a junior year
to a senior year
there is a a mental maturity a physical
maturity that continues to happen
i mean i probably got 10 12 pounds
bigger
you know between my junior and senior
year just through hard work
lifting i was finally getting done
growing and being in you know
that to where i started to fill out and
you start to become a man
and yeah a lot of these guys might not
be able to show the fact that they've
transformed themselves or
taking the next step up or whatever it
may be and it's going to pose problems
for them and of course the nfl too as we
go here
into the future i mean for starters the
nfl doesn't know what's going on we
talked earlier about the reality the nfl
would seriously consider
moving games from sunday to saturday to
backfill the vacancy created by no
college football
need to know whether or not there's
going to be college football before you
start that process of getting
an exception to the broadcast anti-trust
exemption that prohibits the nfl
currently
from broadcasting games on saturdays or
fridays between labor day weekend and
early december you got to get those
wheels in motion
you got to be planning it you got to be
thinking how are we going to broadcast
this do we sell games to networks do we
do it direct to consumer
do we do it streaming what do we do
these are all things that would need to
be figured out
in a fairly compressed time frame even
if they knew right now
chris so they they are watching and
waiting for that decision
then comes the issue of the draft there
had previously been a report that the
nfl has told college football
we're not interested in moving the draft
from late april
if you have spring football but you know
what if it ultimately happens
if there is spring football if that's
where the college football season goes
or if that's where half of it goes
do you really think the nfl is going to
say
sorry we we will do without we will do
without that important information that
we need before we can make these
draft picks into which we will invest
you know millions of dollars
uh you know the i i think that and and
also
to the extent that it it holds together
the draft eligible players who otherwise
would say see you later if the draft is
going forward in april
football is happening in the spring
they're not going to stick around and
play they're going to go get ready for
the draft so
you're helping college football you're
helping yourself i think it's a
no-brainer to move the draft if
if a significant chunk of college
football happens in the spring well
that's why they got to figure this out
too
i mean because let's just say let's say
clemson
let's say the icc goes and says we're
just gonna wait till this spring
well i don't know i mean what are they
gonna do are they gonna make trevor
lawrence play spring football
like that that doesn't seem right so
clemson can't make him do anything he
taps out
see you later that's right well i think
you're gonna have that i mean we're
already seeing that
with the guys that kind of know they're
in the first round conversation
you know they're they're dropping out
well they're why
what what's there to risk right they're
not gonna play spring football that's
not gonna happen
so these teams are going to have
different looking teams they're going to
have to
at least reorchestrate their their uh
their roster
because i think they are going to be
missing those guys now what happens with
those guys who sit out i mean do you
have two drafts
you know do you have one where it's like
hey we got a bunch of these guys who
yeah through the nfl we all kind of
valued them as first second third round
guys
do you do that and then maybe get them
off the board and then go to the guys
who played in the spring because yeah
guys that
are like on the fringe of the nfl oh my
you know i'm hearing i might be a late
round draft pick
or i have a you know undrafted free
agent they're going to play football
because they need to they're going to
try to improve their stock
so to me it poses a lot of problems
there and i don't know how that exactly
works
now i i think it's one draft it's one
draft only
it doesn't get expanded with extra
rounds remember that idea came out for
this year because of all the uncertainty
the nflpa is never going to agree to
more rounds it's always better to have
fewer rounds
and then it's up to the teams to go out
and attract the undrafted free agents
seven rounds one time 20 21 they're
gonna have to decide
when to do it and one of the keys is
going to be when college football
season will unfold and it very well
could be half of it's in the fall
and half of it's in the spring brian
goodikoons the packers gm
mentioned yesterday the possibility of
some sort of a combine in december
uh to if there is no college football
season in the fall and you know chris i
don't know if we talked about this
recently or not i talked about this with
somebody the idea that
can we even have a scouting combine in
february in the middle of the pandemic
are we even at the point
people are already cancelling things
into early 2021
will it make sense to bring all these
kids to indianapolis for a week
in early 2021 in february uh i
i have a feeling we won't be there i
have a feeling there won't be any media
there
if there is it's going to be a very very
small crew probably employed by the nfl
and appearing on nfl network other than
that everybody else will be shut out
um if they even have it i mean so
december for some sort of a combine how
can you do that
you know we're already seeing teams that
are
at the disadvantage of not being able to
bring in players to work out now
yeah because of the issues with testing
and clearing them
so it's it's a mess all around but the
nfl's gonna have to get very creative
here potentially
the first thing is they just have to
know what college football is doing
and they're not going to press college
football for an answer because they are
very respectful of their free farm
system that is college football
but i'm sure that there are people in
the league office right now that wish
college football would make up its damn
mind so the nfl can start making some
decisions yeah they're gonna
you're right that domino's gotta fall
first before the nfl can figure out what
they're gonna do
and you know it seems like we're still a
a few weeks away from college football
figuring that out and you know
it's really weird the nfl in college
they might have to change some rules
they might
you know again for for the people like
trevor lawrence you know i don't
you know just think of him that's the
guy i'm going to use because we're all
kind of putting him as the number one
pick in the draft and all that
he's the best guy to talk about here but
you know
okay what if clemson doesn't play
football you know how does in the nfl
evaluate him going forward i think
that's a real question you're right like
bringing it up because
i don't think the combine's going to be
a safe thing i don't know if the nfl is
going to want to deal with that getting
people from all different parts of the
country coming to one city
i don't know if indianapolis would be
real happy about hosting that either
you know but if you have an area scout
in the clemson area
you know a guy like trevor lawrence he's
gonna have to stay in shape ready i'm
not playing football but
what maybe they have unlimited like
workouts for teams this year
if a team wants to send a representative
and do things the right way hey
every wednesday we'll have trevor
lawrence work out for one team whatever
it may be there are so many moving
pieces and targets here
that they got to figure out that are
going to affect people's lives and
uh we're just at the very beginning
phases of all this
and and remember last year once the
pandemic hit
all the workouts ended no visits no
workouts no
pro days nothing and uh that may be the
reality again from the nfl going forward
first step though what's college
football going to do
hopefully we'll all get an answer
somewhat sooner rather than later let's
take a break when we return
some what's more likely including darius
slay with some strong comments about his
former head coach more pft live coming
at you right now
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports